so the second program is going to be
more focused on transcriptomic data
analysis or rna-seq and we're going to
talk about bulk rna-seq when you extract
your rna from the whole tissue
and you kind of analyze levels of gene
expression
and compare them between different
groups or creating different contrasts
but we'll also talk about single cell
rna seq when you extract rna with a
barcode that can make it uh you know
specific to a cell
and so this is an exciting field with a
lot of new methods that are becoming
available not all of them are simple to
use and in many of them you need to
use them
knowing how they were how they work so
how the data is prepared but also what
are some of the standard procedures and
considerations about the assumptions
that we have and about the conclusions
that we will have from our analysis
so we will talk about
uh first of all the biology of
transcription as a proxy for translation
how can we actually use
uh the abundance the quantity of rna of
a specific type
to infer
how this will turn into a specific
protein so this is kind of the most
common use case right we want to
identify some functional state and we
say that the mrna is the proxy that
allows us to accurately
identify which genes are actually which
protein coding genes are being expressed
and that is why we think this leads to
some functional
change now there are several different
methods to measure and quantify rna but
we will exclusively focus on next
generation sequencing and for next
generation sequencing there are several
levels that you can kind of use that
data to analyze what's going on so one
of them is just to look at genes and
these are protein coding genes
another one is to look at alternative
splicing events where you have multiple
exons that connect together and you
would like to understand how that leads
to different transcripts or different
isoforms so to say of the same gene
and so that oftentimes is a very useful
technique to be able to understand what
is actually going on because not in
every case
loss of function is associated with a
low level of expression for a particular
gene so we'll talk about the differences
between gene
and transcript level analysis but we'll
also talk about how to look at that
detail by making sure that we are
actually developing a transcriptome from
our own data and only then going through
the process of annotation
now we will try to apply this in the
context of a biomedical research project
and so we'll
talk about how uh bioinformatics allows
us to essentially connect clinical and
omics data
how it allows us to address questions
around diagnostics and
applications of therapeutics so we will
kind of extend our understanding of
this expression of genes isoforms and
proteins
translation into proteins to then ask
more biomedical type questions from the
data that we will explore
the program will have several different
sessions we'll start from just the basic
logic of what i explained how is that
processing done and what are the
important steps in that pipeline and the
important steps are going to be
how the data is prepared with minimal
artifact so that our conclusions about
it at the very end are actually reliable
something that we can trust and so we'll
talk about different methods of
data preprocessing or cleaning
we'll talk about mapping how can we map
on the transcriptome on genome how do we
actually identify those alternative
splicing events etc and then we'll talk
about how can that data be quantified
and used to represent a difference
between conditions so in the most simple
experiment you will have
several replicas in one condition
several replicas in another condition
and because they have been
kind of produced in a controlled way you
can you know make biological
interpretation based on these
differentially expressed genes and we'll
talk about plotting uh volcano plots and
things like that but also about
downstream interpretation how do we
connect those differentially expressed
genes with gene sets
like pathways gene ontologies etc and
how do we make sense of what's actually
going on
now to do that we will have to cover all
of the steps from the basic alignment as
you see here with the reads aligned to
the reference genome to then
quantification
analysis of variance
and understanding of whether it is the
right approach to be able to compare
multiple uh conditions and how do we
actually go about more complex data sets
where instead of just two contrasts you
all of a sudden have many
how can you analyze that kind of data
and that is again bringing us back to
that question of data mining and
classification really being able to work
with larger and more complex data sets
and extract meaningful insights by using
non-linear methods of
machine learning and and feature
selection
so then we'll also talk about single
cell transcriptomics so an exciting
technique becoming very very popular
many cores are now adopting uh 10x
genomics and other machines to be able
to produce single cell data question is
what can we do with it and how do we do
it so that we are in control of that
analysis and we know how to ask
biological questions and actually get
answers to those so to do that we will
talk about
typical approaches so the standard
output being the umap or the t-sne
presents us with a clear picture
that unfortunately is not
trivial to explain because it really
contains a lot of information that has
been adapted to a
particular hyperplane and it's difficult
to connect back to biology so we'll look
at how we can use such methods of
dimensionality reduction to start asking
biological question going back to the
statistical comparisons that we've
explored in the bulk rna seq course and
how do we then can also ask additional
questions about for example pseudo time
how can we track trajectories where gene
expression levels actually represent a
continuous process
then we will look at the full pipeline
again from understanding of what is in
our data to then being able to ask
specific questions and then all the way
to downstream interpretation now all of
these are going to be given in the
context of several different project
examples and we'll talk about
patient-derived synographic models where
we will compare tumor and the
microenvironment we will talk about
immune cells
and ability to understand different
subtypes of cancer we'll talk about
macrophages how
the complex immune responses
could actually be both
detrimental and
supportive of
tumor development
and we'll also talk about early stage
cancer detection like biomarkers in
exosomes so a number of different types
of projects that we will look at will
offer also a collection of curated data
sets that you can kind of try to apply
some of the methods that we went over in
the program to something that is more
relevant to maybe your research
interests and we did call this
transcriptomics for
chronic diseases so those are the types
of examples that we're going to use but
if you would like to then use it to a
data set of your own that is also going
to be possible and we have several ways
that you can do that including talking
to someone that can guide you through
that process discuss your project with
you and help you kind of arrive at those
results